there's always been like that theory
that once Apple comes out with a new
phone they start with your old one every
one of these crazy headlines always has
both sides and it's so easy to just look
at our side which is new phone comes out
might get slower that's done the other
side Apple realizes that they want to
make great phones and these batteries
are not that amazing that they can hold
the same voltage for years and years and
years so after a year or two they're
gonna start asking less of the battery
they're gonna voltage down the CPU a
little bit so that the battery can keep
giving you all-day battery life but the
CPU is a little slower but now you still
have all-day battery on a two-year-old
phone because they figure you would
rather more battery than a slightly
faster two-year-old phone what happens
when it feels like the battery is also
going away it will and then your phone
just feels old so the idea is like get a
new battery not a whole new phone if you
need a new CPU that's way different from
just replacing the battery but Apple's
not telling people that so you hear the
other side which is the headline which
is yes your phone is actually slower
yeah and that sucks